How much do
you know about your security detail?
I mean, how much do I know about.
This is just the beginning.
This is my war alone.
And I'm the last person
standing between them
and what they really want.
And what is that?
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my new secret invasion video.
Marvel dropped a bunch of new footage, a
bunch of new scenes with the Easter eggs.
We'll break it down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will be doing episode videos
for it when it releases.
They just delayed it till June.
It used to be in May.
but the big thing they're using secret
invasion for in the MCU
is to set off their bigger Marvel Phase
five arc like the rise of the villains,
their dark reign arc just kind of the vibe
they're going with in Marvel Phase five,
which is basically the progression
that things went in the comics.
Like you went from Secret Invasion
with the Skrulls trying to invade to
a version of Dark Reign where the villains
take positions of power.
So there are a bunch of new scenes.
We start with Nick Fury.
It looks like he's entering a cemetery
that they use for clandestine meetings,
probably with TALOS or his daughter.
Emilia Clarke's character we did confirmed
that Emilia Clarke is playing
Taylor's
daughter. I'll talk about her in a second.
He could be preparing to meet with Everett
Ross, who's also a fugitive now,
because Val basically arrested him
during the events of Black Panther.
We're kind of forever.
And we have Maria Hill.
He could also be meeting with her again,
too, who's a big part of the series.
There's a scene of him
reuniting with TALOS
for the first time since Avengers Endgame.
They actually explain that what happened
is after the blip, after everyone came
back, the Hulk snap, Nick Fury comes
back, Iron Man winds up defeating Thanos
by snapping the nano infinity gantlet.
He dies.
They have his funeral in the events
of everything
that had happened between Infinity War
and Avengers.
Endgame broke Nick Fury,
and he just took off to his space station
and has been stewing.
They're taking a vacation,
basically from reality.
They had a teaser for that
during the Spider-Man far from home
Post-Credits scene,
even though they played it in a more jokey
kind of way, everybody went to work
and got my shoes.
Samuel L Jackson says the whole idea
during secret invasion is
they would explain that basically
the death of those original Avengers
that did die during Endgame broke
Nick Fury, and he wasn't really sure
about what to do next.
So he went to the space station to try
and figure that out for a couple of years.
Like it's been a couple of years
since he's
been back to Planet Earth in
I believe it's still 2025.
During the events of the series,
Getting ready to head into 2026.
So that was part of the reason
why you saw TALOS
and his wife pretending to be Nick
Fury and Maria Hill during Spider-Man
far from home
because they were manning the Fort
for those couple of years
that Nick Fury was on the space station.
There's a new scene of Nick Fury
and Maria Hill, and another meeting
seems less clandestine.
They seem a little bit more relaxed.
Cobie Smulders also explained that
since Avengers Endgame, when Nick Fury
was brought back,
he's been ignoring Maria Hills messages.
She's been trying to contact him
for the last couple of years
and he just hasn't answered her.
There's a brand new scene of Ben Kingsley,
a deer who's playing one of the main
villains. Graphic.
He's not a character from the comics.
He's a character they created
that's based on the ones
from the original Captain Marvel movie.
He's meant to be a leader of a group
who was radicalized
from those original good skrulls
that you saw in the Captain Marvel movie.
His group eventually breaks from TALOS.
His main group of Skrulls,
and they slowly start
infiltrating Earth's society,
sometimes by force when it's necessary.
But originally their evil group of schools
didn't start out being evil.
They just grew tired of waiting
to find a new home.
The way Samuel L Jackson
explains the basis for this,
like the reason why the skrulls
are invading in the first place
or this bad group of skrulls is invading,
is that at the end of the first Captain
Marvel movie, Nick Fury promised Halo's
in the other skrulls, which are meant
to be good characters in the MCU.
That was the big twist
because they're evil in the comics.
He promised all skrulls
that were part of their race.
A new place to live in
hasn't been able to find one since
the events of the first Captain
Marvel movie back in the nineties.
So they've essentially been a people
without a home since the nineties.
In this way,
this evil group gets radicalized
within their larger group of good Skrulls
they've grown tired of waiting, like when
we finally going to have an actual home.
So fine, we'll do it ourselves, like post
all the Thanos memes and they decided
to just take the earth instead.
Like we don't have a home of our own
after 30 plus years, so fine,
we'll just take planet Earth.
And that's why you have Gravity
and his group of Skrulls
trying to take positions of power,
replacing people around the world,
slowly infiltrating Earth's society.
They kind of dealt with this concept
during Falcon and Winter Soldier.
This whole idea of displaced people
after the snap, like what happens
to all the people that didn't get snapped
and moved to different countries?
You have this organization called the GRC,
the Global Repatriation Committee,
who's supposed to be kind of
like they give it a really bad vibe
in Falcon Winter Soldier,
basically sending everyone back
to where they came from, regardless
of what their circumstances are in present
day like,
even though they made a home
in some other country.
There's a new scene of Emilia Clarke
with her father, TALOS.
She's playing a character named Gia.
It's spelled G.
I h I think I'm pronouncing it correctly.
They'll probably pronounce it a little bit
differently when we get the next trailer.
She was actually meant to be
the little girl
Skrull that you saw in the first Captain
Marvel movie he was reunited with.
Like when they found
Marble's Space station hidden in orbit
and they rescued all those girls.
He found his family.
The little girl was Emilia
Clarke character,
and she's just grown up into an adult
since then.
There's another scene of her looking
in the mirror here at her Skrull Forum.
So this is what she looks like
as a skrull.
She said that her relationship
with Taylor's with her
father is going to be strained
in a point of focus during the series.
She's meant to be this refugee kid
who had tailored for a dad
because of all the things
that Taylor's and Nick Fury were doing,
all these clandestine things.
Her childhood wasn't that happy.
So there's a lot of resentment
between her and her father.
They actually did introduce
Taylor's daughter in the comics, but
it was very recently was Meet
the Skrulls number one in 2019.
So she wasn't part of the original Secret
Invasion comic book storyline.
I believe during the series
she's going to be using the human name
Nell when she's pretending to be a human,
like when she's running around
looking like Amelia Clark
and she has some kind of relationship
with Ben Kingsley, a dear Gravity villain
character, because remember, their group
comes from within Taylor's larger group.
There's a brand new scene of Olivia
Colman's union.
Jack Carter in her office is holding out.
That was meant to be
a metaphor of her vigilance.
She said that her character
is supposed to be stone cold,
kind of like a British version of Val.
Her full name on the series is Special
Agent
Sonya Failsworth,
which is going to be a big Easter egg
callback to the first Captain
America movie.
Her father is meant to be.
James Montgomery Falls Wirth,
who was part of the Howling Commandos,
and he's meant to be the original Union
Jack in the MCU, and she's just taken
the mantle as she's gotten older.
When I say she's supposed to give off
some Val vibes, you see her in the trailer
getting ready to torture
some of the skrulls for information.
Just like Val.
She's interested in protecting
her own country by any means necessary.
Doing kind of shady things.
It's just that she comes from Great
Britain instead of America.
There's a couple of new scenes of Rhodey,
and Don
Cheadle says that since Avengers Endgame
Rhodey he's got a couple of big upgrades.
He's become the US president's right
hand man.
So politically
he's become way more powerful.
That's why he's rolling around
with all these people, these attendance.
But he still represents
the military industrial complex.
He's just an advisor to the president
from the military.
There's rumors during the series
because we're heading into dark rain here.
We know that Thunderbolt Ross
is going to become the US
president by Captain America four.
Is it during secret invasion?
Well, either find out the previous US
President that Rhodey has been working
with is a squirrel in disguise,
or he winds up being assassinated,
paving the way for Thunderbolt Ross
to gain the presidency in the whole idea.
There's that thunderbolt.
Ross and Val will take credit for finding
and getting rid of the bad
skrulls and ride that wave of popularity
into the White House.
Val is already the director of the CIA.
She's already very powerful.
Thunderbolt. Ross
is just the other piece of that puzzle.
They've already recast
Harrison Ford as Thunderbolt Ross.
They're in the middle of shooting
Captain America for right now.
I'm not expecting him to appear
in secret invasion,
but I think there might be a cameo
from Val just to link this all up and help
set up their dark reign arc
in the whole idea is that when Thunderbolt
Ross gains the presidency, he starts
doing things his way in America,
protecting America,
doing all kinds of shady things,
turning it into something akin
to a police state,
which is where Val starts
to go off the rails and use the weapons
plus program.
We have the whole plot in Captain America
four, where the leader comes back
from the Incredible Hulk movie and turns
Thunderbolt Ross into Red Hot.
So that's just the beginning.
Like, for instance,
Val is going to use the weapons
Plus program
to create the Sentry, which is all part
of the Thunderbolts movie.
So they're paying off all these long
running Easter eggs in the background
with Val and Thunderbolt,
Ross's character, but in a Dark Reign
arc as the villain sort to take over.
They're doing the same thing in Daredevil
Born Again, which I just did
a preview video for where Kingpin
is running for mayor of New York City.
So Thunderbolt Ross taking the U.S.
presidency, kingpin
taking the mayorship of New York
and working with a bunch of villains
to clean up his problems.
That's where we get to the Thunderbolts
movie because Val basically creates
the thunderbolts, and it's
meant to be a version of Dark Avengers
with a thunderbolt vibe,
a team of Avengers, the Thunderbolt Ross
the U.S.
president can control.
There's a brand new scene of Everett
Ross in a room with a bunch of evidence
and newspaper clippings in the background.
Like he's gone full Charlie Day
theory, conspiracy meme in the background.
This could be in Nick
Fury's hideout, Maria Hills hideout,
where they've just been tracking
a lot of the evil Skrulls
A lot of you also asking about the
Super Skrull because we have the Captain
Marvel two movie, the Marvel's
We have Secret Invasion.
There's a lot of skrull based stories
that are happening
in the next couple of years.
Are they eventually going to do
the Super Skrull?
Well, during the Secret Invasion trailer,
there's a scene of Emilia Clarke's
character finding this Russian base
inside an abandoned power plant
that might wind up being Chernobyl.
That could just be another random
power plant
where the evil Skrulls
are constructing a device.
And the rumor right now
is that has something to do with them
trying to create a Super Skrull.
And that's why
they would need an abandoned power plant,
because they need that much power
to charge up their device.
So we could see some Easter eggs
for Super Skrull during secret invasion.
We might also see some Easter eggs
for the hulking character
who's part of the young Avengers.
They've been slowly putting together
young Avengers in the background
of the MCU, introducing characters.
But the funny thing about Homecoming
is that in the comics,
he has nothing to do with the Hulk
related characters.
He doesn't have gamma powers.
He's green because he is a Skrull like
he is the skrull prince.
So it makes sense that they're going to do
Hulk laying.
They would introduce him
in a skrull based storyline.
So that's basically what's going on.
During the Secret Invasion series,
they said they're going
with the very Captain America
Winter Soldier thriller mystery
kind of vibe where there's this conspiracy
that they're trying to uncover
in Nick Fury is just on his heels
most of the time.
Not really sure what's going on.
Samuel L Jackson also said
one of the other reasons for having him
not wear the eyepatch
like he doesn't wear the eyepatch for
most of the series
is just to make Nick Fury
look more vulnerable
in a way that he hasn't in the past.
Like in the previous Marvel movies,
like phase one, Phase two, Phase three.
He seemed like a very powerful character
who was very sure of what
his next course of action should be.
Drop F-bombs,
pushing the Avengers all over the place.
But by the events of the series, it's
been a completely 180 and he has no idea
what's going on and how to deal with it.
And it's supposed to be
a big part of his arc during the series.
But I do believe that
he will be instrumental
in putting together
the next Avengers team.
We're supposed to see a teaser
for that, like Falcon's new Avengers
during the Captain America four movie.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
in the brand new scenes
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
Review any questions about
what's happening during Secret Invasion.
Just in general, I'll do more videos.
When we start getting some more footage,
everyone click here for that
brand new Guardians of the Galaxy
3 trailer
with new footage and click here
for my brand new Mandalorian.
Season 3 Episode 6Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.